hey what's up guys thank you guys for
watching just kidding news and guess
what this video is sponsored by Adam and
Eve Adam and Eve is an adult wellness
company that sells sex toys and other
adult related products so sex toys is a
really good way for you and your partner
even you and yourself to discover more
about what you like or what your partner
likes so me and Geo
we've been together for 12 years this
year and you know sometimes being to get
really routine so a lot of times she has
a bunch of sex toys that she could bring
in and it's pretty fun and it helps me
understand her better and how to
pleasure her better so it makes the sex
life way better way more interesting and
plus you're probably stuck at home way
more these days so if you want to
explore with yourself this is the best
time we're really excited about
partnering up with Adam and Eve because
they ship in discrete plane boxes if
you're worried about privacy and also
they have a 90-day risk free no-hassle
return and if you have any questions you
can call or email them and they have a
24/7 customer service number that you
can cause well even if you're in the
middle of the act and you got a question
like the battery ran out you can call
them immediately get some answers and
right now you get 50% off one item plus
free shipping in the United States and
Canada if you use the code jkn so go to
WWE comm or go to the link in the
description below some good news please
Oh what do you got is it all good news
no I mean like the feel-good music my
pool is almost done being made what's
not good news now you have no one to
invite over oh oh you guys aren't gonna
come over well this just under ten
people under 10 under 10 oh that's true
we just want to invite ant that's easy I
just keep it under test I know
I know I know all these construction
workers don't give a [ __ ] about this
virus they come over every day sit still
me and G or just looking through the
window we don't want to talk to them the
other yesterday the Builder of our home
they came to inspect some stuff that
they said they were gonna inspect but
they were a group of like 20 people boys
you're not social distancing yeah
necessary no was at least 10 though oh
geez I think people that still have jobs
right now they're like [ __ ] door what's
gonna keep going forward pendent
contractors they gotta bring it girls
any landscapers do plumbers are probably
like yo we're still working yeah you
still got pipe injuries are probably
gonna have a lot of work because people
are flushing those all kinds of [ __ ]
down there because they don't blow paper
I heard UK's like sewerage system is
it's backed up a little bit they're
scared of a gridlock Oh gridlock well it
has been cuz they get those big [ __ ]
gelatinous balls that they have to this
is a real thing no no they get these
huge giant balls of people putting hand
wipes and baby wipes and all kinds of
[ __ ] down the toilet yeah and then also
mix that with cooking oil people put
cooking on to other sinks and so it goes
in the sea get this it creates these
giant [ __ ] things that block up the
sewage system and they have to send
Walker's in there with like pressure
washers and blast them apart it's a
Adams ruins everything I didn't watch it
did I read this okay so which probably
informed his article I find him very
biased he picks one side of something
and doesn't explore both sides of things
gonna be that one side and goes all the
way in on that side yeah I think it's
lazy ever thought the tool what is it
isn't he picking the worst of the two
well there's two arguments for
everything right even like for example
the best I guess he's like taking away
the misconceptions he tries to but he
did the Shia's job on guns I've ever
seen anyone do oh my god okay okay
anyway we're talking about good stuff
here okay so it's 56 year old former
beauty queen from Quebec she won a
lifetime lottery back in 2013
which means she receives $1,000
spit stipend every single week and so
she has decided to just give away all
that money to charity
oh wow so she's been doing it since 2013
and we're just reporting in that because
we need some good news that's awesome
beat to this and make it sick dance I
wasn't paying attention to what you're
saying
tick-tock dances Nikki it's really kind
of more advanced than that but okay this
tick tock trend dances oh but she said a
woman won the lottery has given away all
the stuff to charities $1,000 a week
dollars a week she gets yeah
that's a good question what was it blows
a total 30 years or some [ __ ] they don't
they also don't write that article
that's my best that's what a mess
yeah so I will show you a small little
clip of her and her talking about it and
her charity and what she does and the
good stuff this is the ticket I win with
and this is the football she French
stronger rebellion clothing Oh
so French Canadian French can you when
you get born you don't have anything
when you get bored and when you go
you're going with nothing English is a
bad oh yeah with what you did here
that's so true try to promote good team
so good deed it can be so many things it
can be about today
the food is can be transport to go to
the hospital it can be just missing
somebody on the phone because they're so
lonely so it can be so many things I
think happiness coming from the heart
okay so it's nice love and your bar and
your all new everything you know it's
can be really fun but you don't need
that to be happy
I like her she's awesome
I want to give her a hug no as they oh I
don't know if I brought this up before I
was talking some I was like y'all
everybody was gone
on every issue would you still want all
the stuff that you say oh hell no wait I
have to think about that wait you say
one more time if everyone was gone out
the first started it was just you yeah
would you still want all the stuff that
you thought you needed to be successful
because I want to be on a tropical beach
with lots of kittens and I think I still
would want that okay all right that was
extremely creepy you don't care about
movies or being a TV show what if you
could consume everything that happened
in the world before everyone left no no
no no so long this is like this is like
I made a vegetable I want a Lamborghini
truck so go on a big mansion I want to
be able to shop at anytime I want people
to recognize me will never say I want to
be famous because I want the header on a
claim the walking the streets of people
oh my god is such a size that freaks me
out I don't like that it comes with it
so I wouldn't want anymore
yeah but so that's the thing like if he
goes I'm ego there's no one else around
you there's no more ego you wouldn't
care you've been like if I would want to
be on TV show because I like sharing
stories like that is the whole point was
like share people's stories and connect
and relate to people if there's no
people in the world really there's no
point in me being on a TV show anymore
stories yeah like I would just do the
things that make me happy alone which is
like pet kitties on his tropical beach
with my husband yeah clothes want to be
famous as [ __ ] it so happy dopey god
damn it yeah we would be crazy like in
my scenario of that like if I could like
let's say all humans were replaced by
robots mm-hmm and and then I'm the only
one left I think I'd be okay because I
would they were good robots could still
operate the plane so I guess don't go
skydiving
TIFF you often say the darkest [ __ ] ever
in the nicest way have you noticed that
about no I don't think you would and I
try to really soften it because it's
actually way darker I believe that was
on the inside
they the way you have it on the inside
yeah I did just a little cherry on top
it's a really nice cherry nice cadence
yeah I don't know if I would I mean
because like we all say that we want to
get famous and all this to help take
care of our family and all that type of
stuff is not really first because that's
what society has told us that's what
we're supposed to say it's for us and
then we also want to shine on these
homes why you want it's not just like an
ego thing but it's also like I work damn
hard for this Bentley I worked damn hard
on this Lamborghini and I want people to
know how hard I work and I deserve to be
able to do that
no yeah we also constantly do it don't
effing because here's the thing
unconsciously people tip when I beat up
a hooker I want the hotel staff just
trying to help me cover it up okay so if
Casey was the only person that mattered
as far as looks and stuff like that you
would dress how he wants you to look and
then maybe sometimes what you want to
wear but we dress to impress other
people we'd like the copper oh my god
his way but all of their aesthetics
would be exactly what he wants if you
only care about how he how he viewed you
where is it otherwise you would look at
what you look at when you're at home by
yourself on a Sunday so that means you
are dressing to impress all the other
people that are not him your fake is
[Laughter]
good because we know when we when we
look good we feel good and when we look
good other people will take notice of us
looking good and those compliment also
feel good oh my god if that's such a
nice color on y'all ass oh thank you so
much comfortable I say thank you to be
nice and not be a [ __ ] and reject it
but honestly I kind of feel a little
weird on people point yeah I'm with you
TIFF I will say that I wouldn't put on
makeup or a closer stuff because I I
like being comfortable in sweatpants and
t-shirts and stuff are you good if I
have to go out and look good like I want
to like look my best aníbal yeah but
like I don't feel like that I don't feel
like I would do that if there's other
you well here's my camera oh yeah
I understand because I don't like the
fame the fame part of like people be
like oh my god you because it makes me
very uncomfortable cuz I don't know how
to respond to the jacket that the same
way where I'm like I want you to feel
the same way that you're giving me like
how do I make you feel that way to
reciprocate yeah and then there's if
it's too many if it's just constant I
would not want that but I do like the
idea of making people laugh like being
on a show giving them entertainment
helping them relate to other people like
all that stuff I do care about but if
there was no one there to connect to I
wouldn't be able to do my counterpoint
is I dress when I wear a pair of new
clothes it feels good just to wear the
new clothes it's not that I know people
gonna see me the new clothes that's not
what's good about it
I feel good wearing new clothes because
it's crisp or like fresh it's like fresh
it's like and when I see myself in it
I'm like this is a new thing it's like
when I get a box from Amazon and I open
the package I love that part because
it's like a new thing you know I know
what it is inside I'm just like present
even if I just buy batteries I'm like
yeah point is if there's no one else
here though yeah
would you still care about putting on
that new the wood which maybe I mean we
straight up the world would obviously
have a wouldn't it definitely there's
that fact of it but the fact of the
matter is I could do what I still do
right now as long am I think what what
if and I was saying is like I I have no
desire to buy a Bentley or flex on these
home mean they're like at all like if I
had a big pile of money it would purely
be to take us to a tropical beach and
maybe buy up all the kittens like how
could it be the only thing I would want
to spend my money self-produce and
finance our own thing right but it just
you two because it's just you two do you
honestly yeah no I could make something
we could watch I could watch myself I'm
really good I already feel like I do
that with some surprise each other like
he would make his own show I'm a bozo
and then we'd like that's what we watch
all the characters
I um I completely agree with what you
said that somebody had tweeted this
yesterday they said between Kevin sage T
and more I passed on back throwing out
content like it's nothing this
quarantine will be fine and I don't
think that we give each other enough
praise and accolades for the things that
we do because during this time I saw the
Netflix Hulu Amazon Prime all of these
people who are big budgets to do an
enormous and amazing things we're doing
things on well I can only speak for
myself somewhat of a shoestring budget
and bring it so much joy to people eyes
especially right now you know me like
they are consuming more content probably
within the last this last week and over
the next probably two months then they
ever will throughout the next two years
yes yeah we we feel that responsibility
and you get that purpose you get that
connection and that's exactly how you
reciprocate it you might not be able to
do it in that moment but the fact that
somebody did this and I got another one
this guy was like man I'm really going
something bad I lost parents and I'm
healthy spelling yeah your comedy gets
me through that feeling yes is
unparalleled to any amount of money that
I could 100 percent because that's
that's the reciprocity of it what about
homeless but I do it for the people
absolutely that filius on carbon it's a
comprable it's unparalleled it but this
flex it comes with it it's a by particle
is a copy yet amazing or nothing but you
also need to take these after all these
days of being at home alone and so
because before like it got to a point
where vlogging kind of became a chore
for some reason then now that I've been
at home and like I now I actually
gravitate towards the camera and I want
to connect with whoever else is on the
other side of the screen because of
those messages yes
so even though that previous thing I
said about the robots and like never
mind I take it back yeah look I got a
dunk new house like a flex on these hoes
with
these hoes did you see my house flexo
interesting about look I love the bits
it's great but but there's something so
interesting about being in a world where
we're truly you're not affected by the
way that people see your stuff like for
example I've never gotten to make
anything that I didn't think about what
somebody might think of it going into it
like and that almost cuz you have to
ruin something it can ruin something too
so like you know like I've never for
example made a movie that didn't get
influenced by someone the studio or
something like some person or somebody
who's translating a script and they
don't do it the way that you thought it
when you wrote it so like to be
unaffected by anything and to truly have
independence to be able to make exactly
yes
that's the key to unlocking a freedom to
American dream
exactly that's what freedom looks like
having the freedom to be creatively
expressive right I've never tasted that
free and be unaffected by the outside
view of it yes this show right here yeah
there are certain things that you should
say for monetization right right right
but look you have you have free ways to
do it like you guys have that and it's
such an amazing thing you have it and
you have an audience that gravitates to
it and appreciate you guys for giving it
the real because there's some people
like big actors like think about like I
talked about Kevin Hart all the times
one of my favorite people super cool guy
but he's so big
he's so limited on what how really you
can be my god like is it so crazy like
the bigger you get it depends on what
respect Dave Chappelle good season he's
big he's like I'll throw it in the
garbage can I want to see what is it and
I'll come back and make twice as much
money it's a perfect example oh it's a
perfect example exactly what I'm saying
right so you're taking somebody who who
has spoken to so many he reaches so many
people yeah now he has to make a movie
for those people he can't make the Kevin
Hart movie the way he wants to make it
no way he has to make like a very broad
me and my Instagram page exactly post
anymore
something that happens to all of us
if it happens to all of us but it's
something that we should all try to keep
in mind as we make things because you
because we are slaves to the audience's
that watch our things right thank you
like I sold two movies that were for a
young audience like they're there it's
called young adult for a reason like why
a and so that's for them to watch like
it's not for I'm not gonna go into some
building and be like yo you gotta watch
my young adult series like that's for
you it's not for you so it's but bump it
then I got my movie funny story and I
would never go to the Y ay audience and
be like y'all watch really funny story
it's just there's so many different
quadrants and things you have to keep in
mind while you've trying to make
something and it's hard to make it yours
but it's also so important to remember
to be authentic to yourself because the
more authentic that you are and that
translates on camera they are more
accepting when you do fumble and when
you know if they're know god forbid you
do have a moment where the castle
culture is out for you your core
audience black he did not mean it
exactly he watched this guy for six
years I watched him for five I watched
him for ten years he's never said
anything to attack this race this creep
this belief this sexual orientation this
was a joke that was taking out a concept
it might have been in bad taste but
that's not who he is at his core so it's
also important that still be you in
front of that camera and let the people
see that because and that's one of the
that's one of the the benefits to doing
what we do is in blogging and all of
that is because we don't have to be like
in the Deo and just be who the script
tells us to be you can be Bart you can
be Steve TIFF KC Nikki and people will
resonate who you are as a person and
they will appreciate how authentic you
are thank you guys so much for watching
[Music]
[Music]